Okay. let's do an exercise. Now, your task in this exercise is to look at the
Chicago OSM data set and find all the top level tags in this data set. Now,
what we mean top level tags are essentially
all the distinct different types of tags that
you are going to see in this data set. Okay, so osm, bounds, node, tag and
so on. What I'd like you to do is
loop through this data set and create a dictionary such
that each time you see a particular tag, if
that tag isn't already in your dictionary you add it.
At the end, your dictionary should be populated by
all of the different types of tags contained in this
data set. Now the challenge here is that this file
is huge. If we take a look at its size,
I did that just a little bit ago. We can
see that it's just under 2 gigabytes of data. Now
we've talked about two different types of XML parsing in
this course. One is tree-based parsing where we essentially read
the entire document into memory, and then work with it
as nodes on a tree. The other way we've talked
about parsing XML is using a SAX parser or doing
iterative parsing. We actually looked at the iterparse method for element
tree back in lesson three. And that's what you
are going to be doing here. So instead of reading this
entire file into memory. What we are going to do
with iterparse is parse it one tag at a time
and so essentially what you are doing here is
treating each time you see a tag as an event
and for each one of those events, what we are
going to be doing is checking to see from our dictionary
whether we have seen a given tag. Before and I don't mean this specific tag.
Rather what I mean is a tag with this name. So bounds, node, tag, et cetera.
If you haven't seen it before, create a new key in the dictionary. And by the
time you're done parsing the file you'll have
all of the unique tag names. Good luck!